- And then my team was like, "Nate, he callin’ you, fool. Go!” I was like, “Oh, shit.”
I took my jersey off.
In my head, I was thinking about The Waterboy.
I was like, “Man.”
You know, like Waterboy, when they were like, "Water sucks!"
You know what I'm saying? He’s picturing the coach’s face.
I was picturing everybody's face on the team was D'Antoni.
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
Who we got in the pool hall today?
Nate the Great!
- How you doin’, boss?
- Nate Robinson, KryptoNate!
Which nickname do you prefer?
- It don’t matter, man. You know what I’m sayin’?
It’s all love.
- How nice are you on the table though?
- I’m all right. It’s been a minute, bro.
I’m really—I’m good at pingpong, though.
So you should be a lil’ pool shark as many episodes as you've done.
- Hey, man,
hey.
- Let me—
Let me find out. If I win, man—
- Put some money on it,
you know what I'm saying?
Get 50 a ball, 100 a ball.
We’ll see what we talkin’ about.
- I ain't got no shot, man.
This is bull.
- Nate,
you're 5'9",
and the things that you've been able to accomplish
throughout the course of your career,
a lot of people would say
it's virtually impossible to be able to do something like that.
- I just wanted to prove, you know,
so many people wrong
and all the doubters. Like, look,
even though I'm 5'9",
I don't see myself as being short.
I just like to have fun. And
I go out there and play with my heart on my sleeve,
and I show what I got,
and it's been working over the years.
- When it's Nate against the world, man,
how does that feel?
How do you thrive in those moments?
- You know, you rise to the occasion.
My dad always told me, “Man, when the lights come on,
you gotta be ready to perform.”
When it's time, and it's some nights you may wake up, play against LeBron or
play against Kobe and different players,
you just gotta be ready.
When you get the opportunity, you gotta make the best of it.
And I tried to do that.
- Talk to me, man. What was the thing that comes to mind when you think about
the challenges you faced in New York with Mike D'Antoni?
- It was tough, man.
People don't know
the shit I used to go through. I used to try to, you know, have
meetings with him and try to figure out why I wasn't playing.
And he just didn't wanna speak to me.
Ignored me sometimes, and
he would—
- He didn't explain at all?
- Didn't even explain it to me.
- How many games did you go without playing?
- 14, bro.
- 14 straight games.
- 14 straight games, bro. And then like,
when I'm at The Garden, people are screaming, "We want Nate."
They screamed—like, the whole crowd.
Like, imagine 20,000 people screaming,
"Put in Nate. We want Nate."
So, I remember one time, during New Year’s,
I called my mom. I was like, "Mom,
come chill in Atlanta with me.
You know, I need a familiar face, pick-me-up,
cuz I ain't been playing.” I was like,
"It'd be good to have you at the game, just to be there, just so I know you’re there.”
The game goes on.
First quarter,
Coach calls my name, and I didn't move.
I just stood there like, you know, we're in the huddle. He's like, "Nate."
And I was like, "Shit, I know he ain't talkin’ to me."
And then my team was like, "Nate, he callin’ you, fool. Go!” I was like, “Oh, shit.
I took my jersey off.
- In my head, I was thinking about The Waterboy.
I was like, “Man.”
You know, like Waterboy, when they were like, "Water sucks!"
You know what I'm saying? He’s picturing the coach’s face.
I was picturing everybody’s face on the team was D'Antoni.
- [Laughing]
- I was like, "I'm out here.
I'm out here. It's time."
So, I went in the game,
and I made like three, four in a row.
I made a pull-up three, and then after the three that came,
I had a fadeaway jumper, and I was like, "Oh, yeah, it's on.
It's on and crackin’.”
And then we end up going to overtime.
Come to look at the stats, we win the game,
41 points.
- 41 points?
- Yep. Six, seven rebounds. Six, seven assists.
Couple steals.
Had a hell of a game, man.
And I ain't gonna lie, I think I cried after that game cuz it was—I was just so happy.
- Is this your shot?
- Yup.
We'll roll with this.
- Nate, three-time Slam Dunk Contest champion.
Ain't nobody else done that.
First person to ever do it.
Which one's your favorite, man?
- Spud, bringing out Spud.
I got a call from Jamal Crawford one day. He was calling me.
He was like, "Bro!" I was like, "Bro, wassup, Mal?” I said, “You sound excited.”
He was like, "Bro, I am. I got a perfect idea for you for the dunk contest."
I was like, "Bro, shoot it! Wassup?"
He was like, "Bro, you should bring out Spud Webb and jump over him."
And I was like, "Spud Webb?” Like—
I said, "But that’d be too easy to just jump over Spud Webb." They were like,
“It's not about being easy. It's about the scene.”
- Shoutout Jamal Crawford for the idea.
- Yeah, shoutout to Mal. Shoutout to Spud.
We kinda changed the way the dunk contest was.
Cuz before that, it was just, you know,
start bringing out guys like that. Then, you know, jumping over Dwight,
over Superman. That was tough.
That was, that was difficult.
- [Laughing]
- And then that was born, what,
KryptoNate, right?
- Yup. And KryptoNate was born.
- Hell yeah
- That’s what happened.
- How'd those shoes come about, man?
That's what I need answers about more, man.
- I told Nike—I’m like, “Man, I got a perfect dunk
I got a dunk that I wanna do in the dunk contest." And I was talking to them,
and I was like, "But I need some shoes."
And then they came up with
the Kryptonite that was the Foamposite. I was like,
"Oooh, with the green.” I was like, “Yo!”
And I gave ‘em the whole KryptoNate thing, and they were like, "Yeah,
we gonna, we gonna run with this."
They gave me a sleeve and a whole green jersey for the Knicks.
- The green
- But believe it or not, that day,
when they made me the shoes, somebody stole ‘em out my hotel.
- Like, how—OK, so, you had the shoes on you.
- I went to go do all my media stuff.
I did all my media stuff, and I come back to my room,
and they were gone.
Somebody put ‘em on eBay.
Cuz they had never been seen before. Nobody even seen ‘em.
So when they seen ‘em on eBay, they were like, "Yo!"
- So, from the time that they were stolen, how quickly did they post ‘em on eBay?
- Same day. Same day.
- So this all happened before the dunk contest?
- Before the dunk contest.
I was sweating. I was like, "Damn, they stole my shoes"
Then the next day, they found ‘em,
and they got ‘em back to me.
And it was like, do not let nobody—so I gave ‘em to my mom.
It was like, “Mom, here. Hold these.”
- [Laughing]
- “Don’t let nobody take my shoes.
Just hold ‘em there with you.” So she put ‘em up,
and then we got to the dunk contest.
- So, where the shoes at now?
- Nike, they made me a dope-ass
KryptoNate, heavy-ass box
with green crystals. And
it's, like, sitting on top of my,
where my dunk contest trophies are at my house.
- That’s fire.
- So, pretty, pretty dope.
There it is. C’mon, Kid Cudi.
- So we see what you can do with the pool sticks, man.
You still got that shot?
- Let’s go see.
- C’mon.
- Where the magic happens.
- [Laughing]
I’m here with Nate Robinson.
Sixty seconds to see how many shots you can get up, but also, let’s see
how many questions you can answer at the same time.
Are you ready?
- Let’s get it.
I’mma get it.
- Let’s get it, bro. C’mon.
- I’mma take this jacket off, man.
- Alrighty.
Two, one, let’s get it, baby!
- Boxing or Football?
- Football.
- Big Baby or Shaq?
- Man,
uh, Big Baby.
- Shaq’s shoes or your shoes?
- Shaq’s
- What’s your kryptonite?
- What’s my kryptonite?
Uh..
- C’mon, Nate!
- I don’t know what my kryptonite is!
MJ or LeBron?
- Michael Jordan.
- Favorite team to play for?
- Bulls
- Favorite car you own?
- My Porsche.
- Pregame snack or routine?
- Peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
- Peanut butter and jelly sandwiches.
Who you listen to before a game?
- E-40.
- Tell me when to go! Fifteen seconds.
Best city to visit on the road?
- Best city to visit?
Miami!
- Miami. Best fans in the NBA?
- [Laughing]
- Best fans?
Warriors.
- Five seconds.
All-Star Weekend or Super Bowl week?
- All-Star Weekend.
- Favorite teammate you’ve ever had? Two, one!
- Favorite teammate I’ve ever had?
Probably Eddy Curry.
- Eddy Curry. Shoutout to Eddy Curry.
- 89!
Goddamn, you doin’ work out here, man.
- Yeah, I told you, man. It’s what I do.
All backboard. I told you, that's the lick.
Backboard shots.
- Nate, appreciate you for jumping on “Untold Stories,” man.
- You already know, man. Thanks for having me, bro.
I appreciate it.
- We definitely gotta have you back in the pool hall soon, all right?
- Yeah, you already know.
- Already.
- Subscribe to Bleacher Report
for more "Untold Stories".